i know people are struggling with the
cost of living which is why today i
announced a tax plan that delivers the
biggest net cut to personal taxes in a
quarter of a century firstly we're
cutting fuel duty by five pence per
litre coming in tonight and saving a
typical motorist a hundred pounds over
the next year secondly we're raising
national insurance thresholds delivering
a tax cut to 30 million workers with a
typical employee saving 330 pounds and
lastly for the first time in 16 years we
will be cutting the basic rate of income
tax ensuring people keep more of what
they earn now whilst there are uncertain
times ahead and i can't protect everyone
from all the global challenges that we
face the policies announced today will
put billions of pounds back in the
pockets of hard-working british families
everything you've just mentioned is
great for people who've got an income or
who can afford a car but
for people on benefits particularly
universal credit which the obr says will
be effectively cut by five percent due
to inflation in a year they're not
getting anything why not
well as we have done throughout the last
two years we will stand by people and
particularly those who are most
vulnerable in our society that's why
last autumn we improved the generosity
of universal credit we cut something
called the taperey rewarding those who
are in work making sure that they can
keep more of what they earn whilst
they're on universal credit and today we
announce further measures half a billion
pounds of extra funding for local
councils to support those most
vulnerable in their areas but the best
way to help people on welfare over time
is to support them to get into work
that's exactly what we're doing and i'm
glad that there are record numbers of
job vacancies and unemployment is now
back to the low levels we saw before the
pandemic
now for everyone in work or out of work
they are facing the biggest squeeze on
living standards since records began in
the 1950s
i wonder how you felt when you saw that
figure from the obr whether you feel you
can do any more for those people
we are facing the same challenges that
many countries around the world are
facing and that's rising prices and high
inflation inflation here is running a
bit lower than it is in america similar
to what is happening in the eurozone and
there is uncertainty ahead and i wish i
could but i can't protect everyone
against the full impact of those global
challenges but where we can make a
difference of course we will and that's
why the policies announced today are a
significant intervention they will put
billions of pounds back in the pockets
of hard-working british families the tax
plan i announced represents the biggest
net cut to personal taxes in over a
quarter of a century we are on people's
side through this difficult time we all
know you want to want to be a tax
cutting chancellor but your income tax
cut doesn't come in for two years and
you're
raising the national insurance threshold
well i mean national insurance is
something that is also going up the
overall burden of tax is going up isn't
it against what may be your instincts we
announced today
a historic rise in the national
insurance thresholds which delivers a
tax cut for 30 million people worth 6
billion pounds it's the biggest personal
tax cut in a decade it means a typical
worker will be over 330 pounds better
off as a result of our policies 70
percent of workers will pay less tax
even accounting for the new levy and
we've also announced the first income
tax cut in over 16 years to come in in
2024 when the economic picture has
improved i intend to deliver on that and
again this is a conservative government
putting billions of pounds back in the
pockets of hard-working british families